okay last question today is from Carter
Carter says lots of people have mutual
funds and in those mutual funds lots of
people have shares of health insurance
companies if universal health care is
passed whether it's Medicare for all or
some other system do all those people
owning health insurance shares get
crushed well a couple things number one
there are many more players in the
health insurance market that are
probably in most people's mutual funds
than just for-profit health insurance
companies there are nonprofit health
insurance companies there are the
hospital ownership chains there are the
pharmaceutical companies there are many
other players I guess is what I'm saying
so that for-profit insurance companies
will definitely be negatively affected
if something like Medicare for all were
to pass but that's not all that you
might be exposed to if you are a mutual
fund holder but it is a fair question
which is if you're just an average
middle-of-the-road person with a little
bit of money in mutual funds and you
would benefit from the existence of
Medicare for all itself if a bunch of
these companies that depend on health
care being for-profit all of a sudden go
out of business or have to significantly
downsize and their shares the value of
their shares plunge that is going to
plunge the retirement accounts of some
of those people mm-hmm logically there's
something to that but what you have to
remember is that the overwhelming
majority of shares of stock are already
held by the very very rich and even
among those who are not of the richest
tier of the economy but have shares of
mutual funds or stocks they have a
disproportionately small amount so
there's really no way to say to Carter
no you're wrong it would not have any
impact on those businesses but I think
it's also important not to overstate the
importance of that and to not understate
the importance of eliminating the
possibility of a medical bankruptcy
which is a reality right now under our
current system so under Bernie Sanders
plan I would be like a four year
transition process yeah you
medicare-for-all I mean I guess the
people working in the for-profit health
insurance companies would have other
roles they can go
- because care will be contracted out so
there would still be some administrative
roles that could fill in when he talked
about the stock market I mean of course
there would be uncertainty even though
there's a four year transition period
when it's not initially passed or just
even debated of course the stocks gonna
crash but I actually think that you're
getting at the real stock market risk
that exists which isn't individual
mutual funds will have a decrease in
value as a result of the components of
those mutual funds that are impacted by
single-payer health care losing money
yes I think that there will be such a
shock to the system if there were to be
a transition to Medicare for all that
there would be a general market crash at
least initially although ultimately
Medicare for all could provide
significant demand-side stimulus to
people by reducing the amount that
families are spending on health care
your average lower lower middle or
middle class family is going to take the
money that they're saving and they're
gonna reinvest it into their local
economy it could actually be really
stimulative but in the short run it's
gonna be bad
certainly something to brace for - if
Democrats are going to be pushing for
this in the next few years because if
the stock market is facing negative
repercussions from it I mean that's
going to play into the argument of
Republicans as enough yes it is and bill
scher did mention that earlier this week
bill scher said that when you when you
talk about the the total shake-up of
such a major industry aside from the
merits of Medicare for all you have to
consider the strength with which many of
these industries would fight against it
and that's not I'm in favor of Medicare
for all to be super clear but bill scher
was not wrong and saying that you would
have insurance companies fighting for
their lives and that would be sort of
part of what would have to be managed
with very good question Carter I mean
this this is the type of thing people
should be thinking about right well what
how will it of what are other ways in
which it might maybe negatively affect
the average consumer of health care
middle class person in the United States
alright that's it for today we've got a
great bonus show for you stay tuned
david pakman.com slash membership if you
don't yet have access to the bonus show
and of course patreon.com slash david
pakman show which also now at the $5
level gives you instant access to every
single one of our bonus shows